salut comment vous allez aujourd'hui
alors j'ai plein de trucs très cool à
vous montrer aujourd'hui c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est réalisé en
partenariat avec huawei huawei m'a dit
tiens monsieur bruce que tu voudrais pas
venir tester nos nouvelles montres
connectés lounge des trois pros mais
également la watch fidh 2 si vous êtes
là c'est que vous avez vu que je vous
parlais de nouvelles monde de huawei qui
ont été présentés il ya pas longtemps un
milan j'étais c'est très sympa et je
suis content de les avoir parce que
regarder la gelée avec elle fragile avec
moi je les ai au poignet qui permet plus
gelé au poignet c'est la ouate gt3 pro
alors je vous ai parlé de la ouate gt3
et quelques temps je vous ai parlé
également du modèle sportif lounge et et
runner je vous invite à les découvrir
ces vidéos si vous êtes intéressés par
ces modèles parce qu'elles sont très
cool mais là on a un modèle
professionnel vous les prouesses par des
professionnels attention c'est pas fait
pour le travail mais c'est le modèle le
plus complet on va voir des matériaux
extrêmement noble très très très jolie
finition sature était un poids
extrêmement fort chez huawei les
finitions convient retrouver au niveau
de leurs obligés ce soit au niveau des
smartphones des ordinands pas libre f je
vous en parle beaucoup mais il ya
également une deuxième montre un vrai
j'en ai un peu partout de tous les côtés
c'est celle là c'est la ouache fidh de
la watch fille de là elle aussi
extrêmement sympa on a un écran qui est
un peu plus grands bref on a plein de
produits extrêmement coup là regardez
aujourd'hui côté montre on va commencer
par al awad gt3 pro parce que c'est
vraiment l'amour que je préfère et de
loin et que j'ai au poignet voilà mais
vous allez voir vous allez pas bouder
votre plaisir également avec el haouès
feet 2 qui est aussi très cool et qu'en
plus grand écran presse c'est chouette
hein on y va bingo
[Musique]
ok alors on fait un peu place nette on
va se contenter tout de suite sur
l'awadh gt3 pro alors je vous passe très
rapidement le packaging regardez l'âge
est tous un peu dans le coin c'est un
peu le bazar parce qu'il ya tellement
ici mais c'est cool ça ça vous sert à
bien la charge est bon c'est pratique on
s'en doutera vous venez prendre votre
blog de charge le milliard il est là oui
j'ai un bloc de charges par exemple que
j'utilise ici pour mon p50 pro que je
peux utiliser avec ma montre un qui est
très bien samedi recharge du 66 voix de
c'est cool on va parler de la charge en
quelques instants mais avant toute chose
regardez ce truc là attendez je vais en
vue de mon poignet en fait cette montre
là ce qui est vraiment génial c'est que
c'est un bijou l'horlogerie un peu
classiquement les montre un peu
classiquement ce sont des bijoux
convient m au poignet ça donne
effectivement leur mais au delà du côté
heures qu'on va avoir au delà de toutes
les nouvelles fonctionnalités qu'on a
aujourd'hui avec les mondes connectés ce
sont des petits bijoux et c'est
vachement intéressant qu on va où elle
est prise dans ce sens alors attention
là je vous montre avec le bracelet en
titane mais il existe également d'autres
finitions vous a également un bracelet
cuir gris qui va exister on a même un
mec de la fluoro et stahl au maire noir
oui j'ai lu pour vous le dire parce que
le nom est un petit peu imbitable alors
regardez moi ça c'est vraiment une
montre que je trouve extrêmement
prégnante super joli très épaisse mais
c'est un beau bijou et je la trouve
vraiment vraiment vraiment canon alors
il ya deux finitions qui existe vous
avez un modèle céramique c'est un
bracelet en 43 mm en fait 42,9 points
très précis et vous avez le modèle
titane perdez tout le corps titane la
cdu 46,6 enfants direct du 46 mm un peu
plus grands super beau elle est à la
fois sportif parce que moi je les prix
par exemple en salle pour aller faire
mon entraînement et j'ai aucun problème
avec elle ira très très bien elle est
également urbaine elle est très chic
vous la mettez à votre poignet
franchement d'années comme ça ça a de la
gueule hop là je la prends je la pousse
c'est une montre mon tout est plus
simple au niveau des finitions au niveau
des bracelets on peut même venir enlever
un mois ferme et parce que j'ai pas
déployé qui sont très très très gros
envoyé spécial pour très facilement
comme ça on peut venir enlever les
petits feront tajan temps des joues
montre moi j'en ai enlevé 2 1 d'un côté
un de l'autre et puis après ça se ferme
très facilement comme salade et vous le
prenez tac vous appuyez vous rhabiller
sur le côté vous l'ouvrez très simple
super calme là vous avez un corps en
titane tout ça c'est un corps en titane
qui est fait sans soudure donc c'est
d'un seul bloc votre verse un verre
saphir extrêmement résistant qui vous
protégera lorsque la montre à bien elle
vient coter elle vient rencontrer un
coin de portes en quoi noble et
compagnie donc ça c'est résistance est
très cool et le dos et de la céramique
la céramique c'est extrêmement pratique
pour venir vont changer son fils et ça
c'est cool on va retrouver deux boutons
un premier bouton ici voyez tac on
appuie qui permet d'arriver sur le menu
alors le menu je peux venir naviguer
c'est un menu en gris où je veux me
retrouver les applications que je vais
pouvoir me dire également installé
depuis la galerie le réveil les
chronomètres le suivi de santé gérard ma
boussole à température corporelle alors
bon ça je les mesures et c'est pas
forcément l'outil que je vais préférer
le plus samedi la température de ma peau
au niveau de montpellier à 32° quelques
hoquets alors why not mais savait que je
pense que pour le commun des mortels ça
représente pas grand chose donc pas
nécessairement intéressant vous avez un
côté torche tous vos paramètres qui sont
plutôt bien fait le gps qui est la
déclencher l'appareil photo à distance
de la méditation vos contacts la météo
alors il ya d'autres qui sont cool je
vais la mettre au panier pour vous
puissiez vraiment vous rendre compte je
vais avoir plein de chose intéressante
c'est qu'en fait déjà sept montres elle
est faite pour le sport c'est une autre
connecté on n'a plus de sens mode de
sport alors regarde avec vos deux
boutons le bouton du haut je vous ai dit
ça vous permet d'arriver là et le bouton
du bail les vaches quand même parce que
c'est un bouton qui est personnalisable
et moi up la regarde et je clique savoir
mène directement dans les modes de sport
donc ça c'est hyper hyper hyper hyper
canon et pour éviter complètement le
personnaliser c'est à dire que je vais
la pac je viens ici j'ai un petit mode
qui s'appelle bouton bas et là je viens
là signé comme je veux soit pétales maps
mais paramètres trouvé mon téléphone m'a
longtemps mon alarme minuteur
chronomètre le web offre à tout ce que
vous voulez moi j'ai préféré le laisser
sur toute la partie sport ça va très
très bien ça tu d'entraînement mais vous
pouvez faire ce que vous voulez c'est
hyper hyper hyper canon après je monte
très rapidement parce que cette montre
elle est géniale vous avez un grand
écran c'est de la molette cédé 1,43
pouces est extrêmement fluide donc ça
c'est vachement bien une fois de plus -
ouais maîtrise vraiment son matériel on
le voit une fois de plus sur leurs
montres connectés donc ça marche hyper
bien vous retrouver ici tac je clique
l'assistant intelligent leçon diversion
l'assistant intelligent je l'utilisé pas
particulièrement ce pas trop mon truc là
l'affichage de luminosité très bon la
luminosité je peux dire la pousser au
max mais attention à l'autonomie sachant
qu'ici à l'autonomie on nous annonce 14
jours on a une très grosse autonomie
elle se déchire pas particulièrement
rapidement 14 jours en utilisation un
peu standard si vous allez en
utilisation un peu plus intense si vous
arrivez huit jours huit jours déjà vous
avez de quoi faire genre 10 minutes de
charge l'avait mis 25 % de batterie en
plus il vouloir changer de zéro à 100%
en 80 minutes on dira que c'est rapide
pour huit jours vous êtes vraiment
peinard et puis après vous y retrouver
le son vote que d'accessibilité bref
c'est très simple très épuré on comprend
tout lorsque vous êtes ici tac vous
arriver là vous avez vos paramètres
rapidement votre batterie vous voyez
quel jour on est sur le bas vous avez
bien votre historique mme historique de
santé que j'ai retrouvé ici de l'autre
côté la météo mais pour l'instant aux
plages les familles et ici vous allez
avoir votre rythme cardiaque
je suis à 91 tout de suite franchois peu
énervé mais ce po2 l'ensemble en parlant
quelques instants du point de vue santé
méano aujourd'hui ce que j'ai fait j'ai
fait du sport avec et puis après
prévenir savent bien que paramétrer ce
que vous mettez ou pas le sommeil parce
que oui c'est une honte qui vous servira
pour tout ce qui va être sport bien
évidemment et plein de modes différents
alors moi je n'ai utilisé sur le vélo
elliptique j'ai utilisé sur la course à
pied je les utiliser sur un vélo
également et en termes de suivi de
santésuisse a vraiment hyper hyper hyper
canon voyez par exemple ans que je fais
du sport je vais avoir mon indice indice
de course là je vais monter en aérobie
je vous passe très rapidement mais j'ai
vraiment toutes les infos j'ai mon
stress j'ai mon rythme cardiaque
gemma vo2 max enfin bref c'est vachement
vachement bien parce que j'ai plein
d'informations grâce à ses différents
capteurs et le truc est super bien c'est
que à l'arrière garde et vous avez un
tout nouveau capteur c'est waou et
roussine 5.0 en fait ici vous avez deux
fois plus de capteurs de rythme
cardiaque par rapport aux générations
précédentes qui permettra d'avoir déjà
quelque chose d'un peu plus précis et de
là on va pouvoir aller jusqu'à la sp
odieux alors là spo2 pour le commun des
mortels si vous connaissez pas c'est la
saturation en oxygène de votre sans
savoir que dans votre sang vous avez
forcément de l'oxygène qui est véhiculée
par les globules rouges bon on passe un
petit peu l'histoire mais il faut avoir
une saturation qui est élevé alors je
parle entrer dans des cours de
saturation de médecine et de santé on
s'en fout mais bref vous permet de
savoir où est ce que vous êtes et où
est-ce que vous en êtes parce qu'au delà
de l'aspect sport et de tout ce que vous
allez pouvoir à voir avec votre suivi du
rythme cardiaque un autre qui est
vachement des skis si vous avez vraiment
de la donnée de santé si toutefois vous
voulez suivre votre rythme cardiaque
parce que vous avez une pathologie alors
que vous voulez vraiment regarder où
vous en êtes et bien vous pouvez le
faire grâce à votre montre à elle vous
donne votre saturation votre température
corporelle que mon jargon santis un
petit peu votre fréquence du rythme
cardiaque vous avez un vrai suivi du
sommeil vous voyez lorsque vous êtes au
niveau de votre stress et tout ça vous
venez le coupler avec votre smartphone
la gelée mis sur mon pays 50 promet
pouvait prendre n'importe quel
smartphone parce que cette montre elle
fonctionne aussi bien avec bien
évidemment tous les smartphones de
huawei mais également à ios et android
donc ça c'est cool il vous faut
l'application ou huawei sentez-vous à
pouvoir dire téléchargées par exemple
ici dans mon application va vous sentez
regardez j'ai gardé pas mal d'infos sur
ce que j'ai fait aujourd'hui le nombre
de pas je vois mon rythme cardiaque
lorsque j'ai fait du sport l'a alors
être la journée n'est pas terminée mais
je peux savoir henri l'acheter dans la
séance d'entraînement séance de sport je
suis monté jusqu'à 183 g tapella
ailleurs c'est intéressant parce que ma
montre elle me disait whaou a dépassé
les 180 c'est pas normal c'est pas
normal parce que vous pouvez venir la
paramétrer lui dire ok dit moi à quel
moment je tape trop où je tape pas assez
allez je vais vous montrer donc c'est au
niveau du coeur mon point et vous savez
tout connaissez tous sur une histoire le
sommeil je dors pas avec les montres à
c'est pas mon truc donc je le relève le
soir votre stress votre spo2 lâché
plutôt pas mal température cutanée choix
32,5 hockey dans votre appareil ici vous
cliquez sur votre montré sur votre monde
vous allez ça c'est un truc qui est
vachement intéressant vous allez dans
suivi de santé et d'ensuite sentez vous
venez paramétrer tout ça alors le suivi
du sommeil active est suivi du rythme
cardiaque vous laisser en intelligence
il ya un très bien et là vous mettez des
alertes ça c'est vachement cool alerte
de rythme cardiaque élevé moi j'allais
me à 120 battements par minute à vous de
voir en fonction de vous de votre coeur
comment ça se passe mais également une
alerte de rythme cardiaque faible à 50
ppm vais faire la même chose au niveau
de la spo2 une alerte lorsque votre
saturation en oxygène dans le sang sera
basse 90 provence est quand même très
bas il faut le savoir ça c'est plutôt
pas mal à voir température corporelle
j'ai désactivé je m'en fiche le stress
on peut le faire également avec quelques
informations au niveau de votre raison
que ça c'est vachement cool dont vous
voyez qu'en fait cette montre est très
complet pour le sport avec un vrai suivi
avec ce nouveau capteur derrière en plus
couplée à de l'intelligence artificielle
qui va vraiment venir faire le maximum
pour vous donner des résultats
extrêmement précis mais en plus un de
suivi de santé de données de santé c'est
vachement intéressant et lorsque vous
voulez être un petit peu plus zen vous
avez un mode sanitascpt lui permettra de
venir à vous relaxer vous détendre bref
plutôt intéressant mais il ya un autre
truc qui est vachement bien c'est que
cette montre l'art connecter à votre
smartphone bien évidemment vous pouvez
répondre directement à vos appels
téléphoniques depuis votre montre alors
voulu parler comme dans k2000 équipe
comme ça vous pouvez le faire mais si
vous voulez c'est intéressant et ça
marche bien et vous m'associer tout ça
avec votre smartphone votre monter vos
freebox pourquoi pas et vous pouvez
venir l'utiliser lorsque vous faites du
sport vous avez votre sont là vous
changez votre musique directement vous
pilotez comprendrait fait extrêmement
pratique tout en sachant qu'un autre
truc qui est vachement bien c'est que
vous avez plein de cadran alors là le
cadran que j'ai c'est un cadran premium
vous pouvez venir payer et à acheter au
plus pour rien là alors moi j'ai deux
cadrans premium qui sont hyper mauger
celui là qui top et il ya celui aussi
qui est très jolie je vous invite à
venir jeter un petit coup d'oeil
directement dans votre application sur
votre smartphone pour venir si vous
intéresse acheter des cadrans un petit
peu spéciaux après vous en avez plein
qui sont déjà extrêmement jolie comme ça
avec plein d'informations ou jean michel
lahmi cela j'aimais beaucoup si la
galerie mais c'est vrai que j'ai un
petit coup de coeur sur celle-là je
trouve hyper hyper hyper canon c'est
bien évidemment une montée certifié ip
68 résistante à l'eau et à la poussière
5 atm 50 mètres et il a été testé à 206
de pression sous l'eau jusqu'à 30 mètres
vous êtes tranquille il ya un nouveau
truc qui arrivait et si l'on voit où
elle nous a parlé si vous aimez le sport
je vous le montre c'est vachement
intéressant c'est la plongée ça c'est la
première fois que ça arrive ici c'est
très très très chouette vous avez la
plongée plonge en apnée test d'apnée
entraînement à l'apnée vous avez plein
d'informations sur votre plonger sur la
profondeur ou est-ce que vous en êtes
votre fréquence cardiaque un bref c'est
super intéressant et vous et votre
progression donc si vous faites de la
plongée eu notamment d'apnée c'est hyper
canon donc ça c'est la watch voilà ces
modèles titane mais je vous le disais il
ya eu notamment ce qui arrive et qui
waouh c'est tout on mais qui est très
très qu'annoncé celle là c'est la ouate
feet 2 alors là il ya plusieurs
finitions je vous le monde parce qu'en
fait la voile suffit de l est aussi
super super cool pourquoi parce qu'en
fait déjà ils vous ont agrandi l'écran
par rapport à ce que vous aviez sur la
génération précédente
on passe de 1 64 pouces à
1,74 pouces soit 18 6% d'affichage en
plus on a déjà passé à mon poignet pour
vous voyez ça là vous allez avoir un
petit système de touches de montrant
plus standard mais qui est très très
très cool regardez je l'apprends tac la
pause alors je me remets ça là je
l'emmène tag finito l'escargot on n'en
parle plus vous avez votre montre l'a
appelé à regarder ce qui va changer les
couleurs c'est sympa j'appuie ici j'ai
accès à mes différents paramètres mais
différents modes de sport de la même
manière fait avoir exactement la même
manière huawei truth in 5.0 avec mon
suivi et de fréquence cardiaque à
regarder on va la mesure et je pense que
je vais être un petit peu au parce que
forcément lorsque je fais des vidéos je
suis très énervé en 81 86 millions dont
vous voyez j'ai salager mais mode de
sport j'ai 97 mode de sport avec ça je
peux mettre plus de cinq mille morceaux
mp3 intérieure autant dire que j'ai
quand même relativement peinard on a ici
dit jours d'autonomie au sahara on est
cool je peux également la même manière
avec une collection en bluetooth avec
mon smartphone venir répondre à des
appels et de la même manière cette
montre à vous pouvez utiliser avec un
smartphone de huawei bien évidemment
mais également avec android ou ios et
elle étend jusqu à sa ktm très cool et
elle existe regardez large et plusieurs
modèles comme salah hyper sympa avec ce
petit bracelet reçoit un petit bleu gris
j'aime beaucoup qui est très joli mais
je vais également en noir comme ça très
discrète très sympa je n'ai qu'un petit
bracelet cuir aussi voyait qu'une petite
finition cuir donc si vous voulez une
finition cuir et les pieds de surpiqûres
et bien vous pouvez la voir pour un côté
un peu plus habillée donc ça c'est hyper
hyper joli 6 mondes ces produits vous
intéresse bien évidemment je vous mets
les liens en bas dans la description
lounge fille deux disponibles à partir
de 149 euros 99 regardez ici vous l'avez
là je vous mets vince est plus tous les
liens en bas dans la description et la
web watch gt3 pro est disponible à
partir de 369 euros 99 il faut de plus
les liens sont en bas dans la
description d'autant plus qu'à des
offres donc allez jeter un coup d'oeil
vous pour en profiter vous allez voir ya
plein de trucs extrêmement intéressant a
vous de me dire voilà ce que vous en
pensez de ces montres alors moi j'adore
lounge t3 pro alors forcément on aura
des des matériaux plus premium on aura
d'autres finitions beaucoup plus
habillée c'est une honte qui est
extrêmement habillée très très très bel
accueil titane elle est hyper canon
résistants de la deuche vraiment très
très belle en plus le fait d'avoir raté
cette grosse molette là c'est juste
canonissime donc j'adore vraiment super
joli produit mais si vous voulez pas
mettre 60 euros et si vous voulez une
belle montre avec une belle expérience
et qui fonctionnera qui est une belle
autonomie et bien vous pouvez allez sur
la droite vides de pro qui avec un seul
bouton sur le côté et une très jolie
expérience vous à pouvoir faire à plein
de choses que vous pouvez y aller les
yeux fermés sont vraiment des très très
joli produit voilà dites moi ce que vous
en pensez vous encore en commentaire
qu'elle montre vous séduit le plus c'est
ce qu'à une finition particulière est ce
qu a une taille particulière moi je veux
continuer à m'amuser que ce n est alors
pas forcément à faire du sport
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai déjà donné
pas mal de choses et je pense que là ça
commence à suffire hybride raté ça me
fera du bien mais je vais continuer à
m'amuser avec parce que je trouve
vraiment extrêmement canon et j'adore
très très belle finition bravo à white
pas ce que vous en pensez en banque au
mental on se retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler thècle est évidemment
de huawei mais pas qu'eux y de plein de
choses très chouette vous embrasse pour
le soin de vous et à très vite ciao
[Musique]